The last really essential
or salient piece
for understanding the
mechanics of how Bitcoins work
is what we call the
transaction block chain.
So if you recall in
the previous video,
you had a motivating
example of a user, Alice,
who wanted to send
some number of Bitcoins
to another user,
Bob, in the system.
And what Alice has to do to
initiate that transaction was
to construct a transaction--
a record of sorts-- that
contained information
about the transaction
and that was signed with
Alice's signing key.
And that actually contained
Alice's public verification key
and Bob's public
verification key as well.
And that transaction information
was basically broadcast out,
as we mentioned, to the
entire Bitcoin ecosystem.
To all the nodes on the
Bitcoin peer-to-peer network.
And the various nodes
in the Bitcoin ecosystem
are going to sit there.
They're going to
receive information
about this transaction.
But they're also going
to be getting information
about a lot of
other transactions
that are taking place
around the same time.
And what these notes
are going to start doing
is they're going to work on
incorporating this transaction
record into a ledger of all
transactions that have ever
taken place in the
Bitcoin system.
And so what happens is that
each node basically starts off
by taking all of the previously
unincorporated transactions
that they've ever received.
So there's going to be all these
transactions out there that
have kind of happened
within a given time window.
And there's all these
Bitcoin transactions kind
of floating around.
And these nodes-- these Bitcoin
miners as they're called--
are going to receive
information about all
these different
transactions and they're
going to start working
on incorporating
those transactions.
And their first goal is to
collate these transactions
into what's known as
a transaction block.
So if you recall
our ledger analogy,
a single Bitcoin
transaction essentially
corresponds to a proposed
entry in a ledger.
In that capacity,
a transaction block
would basically correspond
to her page in a ledger
where you have multiple
transactions that
are listed in that
page of the ledger.
And the goal-- the Bitcoin
miner's goal-- is to really,
essentially, to take
that page and get it
added to the global ledger book,
the global comprehensive ledger
book.
Now to engage in this sort of
work, what these nodes will
basically do is they'll first
take all the transactions that
have been broadcast out.
And let's say these
four transactions
have been broadcast out.
And they're going to basically
hash these transactions
in pairs in basically
a tree-like structure.
They'll take these
two transactions
and they'll apply a
[? graphic ?] hash function
to those details.
And we'll get a
[? cars ?] flying digest,
goes the same for these
two, and then they'll
take these two
digests and hash them
to get a single digest value.
And this digest effectively
encodes all of the transactions
that were previously
unincorporated
and that were received by
these individual nodes.
And then this
digest is basically
going to be combined with
the hash of the transaction
block that was previously
accepted by the network.
So you can imagine if
there is-- the network
will have a series
of transaction blocks
that were previously accepted.
And in fact, every
transaction block
as I mentioned just
now incorporates
the previous transaction lock.
So this transaction
block will incorporate
the one that was
used just before it,
and this transaction
block will incorporate
the one that was
used just for it.
And it's going to
go on literally
until the beginning
of Bitcoin times.
So this is really
where the Bitcoin--
the beginning of time for
the Bitcoin system, this
is just time equals
zero for Bitcoin.
And they're going to
take this last block
and they're going
to, essentially now,
take this last block and combine
it with this most recent block.
And so if you imagine that
you have now, not just
an individual block, because
each individual block
incorporates the
block before it.
We're not dealing anymore with
an isolated or distinct block
of transactions, but rather
with a chain of blocks
that starts literally at the
beginning of the entire Bitcoin
system.
Now when you do all
of this combination,
at the end of the
day, you're going
to do some cryptographic
hashing and you basically
will end up with a
sequence of numbers.
And this sequence
of numbers will
be derived by incorporating
all these blocks together.
You'll get a
sequence of numbers,
and what we're going
to basically do
is take this sequence of numbers
and convert that sequence
of numbers into a challenge
in a proof of work protocol.
Now I did a separate video
on proof of protocols,
I would encourage you
to watch that if you
want to get a better
sense for how they work.
But the short of it is that
what the Bitcoin mining node has
to do at this point is he'll
take that Bitcoin-- he'll take
the challenge and
he'll have to come up
with a separate sequence of
numbers-- which we typically
termed the proof, or
the proof of work--
and this proof of
work has to have
a very specific
mathematical property.
And what that
property entails is
that if you take the
challenge numbers,
and you take these
proof numbers,
and you concatenate
them together,
and you make them the input
to a cryptographic hash
function, the
resulting output has
to have a large prefix
of zeroes And that
doesn't have to be all
zeroes, but a large portion
of the beginning-- the
prefix-- has to be all zeroes
And if you think about
for a moment, given
that cryptographic
hash functions,
given that their output
tends to look fairly random,
it's unlikely in
any given instance
that you are going
to see a proof.
A proposed proof
that provides you
with a large string of
zeroes at the beginning.
And so what the Bitcoin miner
will have to do is on average,
he'll have to try out
many possible choices
for these proof numbers
until he finally gets lucky
and he stumbles
upon one that has
this kind of off-beat or
strange statistical property.
And the actual difficulty of
finding these proof numbers,
as you can tell, is
dependent on exactly how
many leading zeroes
are required.
The more leading zeroes
you require in this proof,
the longer it takes to
actually solve a problem.
The longer it takes to
actually come up with a proof
that works with respect
to a given challenge.
The fewer zeroes
that you require,
the less time it will take.
Now the exact number of
bits of zero bits required
in the Bitcoin protocol
actually does change over time.
It gets calibrated.
And it's designed
to not, on average,
the average time taken
across the whole system
should be about 10 minutes.
So you want to take about 10
minutes for at least one node
to come up with a valid
proof, but keep in mind
that a lot of nodes are working
on this proof concurrently.
All right, now once this
proof of work is found,
let's say that the proof of
work is eventually found.
The Bitcoin miner will
announce the results
to the overall
peer-to-peer network.
He's going to take this proof
and really all the challenge,
and so on, and he's going to
announce it to all the notes.
And they're now going to
see that, hey, there's
this proof out there,
somebody found it.
Let's drop the other
stuff we were doing
and we're going to now
start to work and build
on top of this new proof.
Remember, this new proof of
this new challenge, these all
incorporate all the
previous transaction blocks.
Really, what they're
starting to do
is starting to work off of a
new, updated transaction block
chain.
And they're going to incorporate
any new unincorporated
transactions into that
new transaction blocking.
Now there are a couple of
points I want to make here.
So first of all, as part of
constructing these transactions
blocks, and really as
part of incorporating them
into a transaction block
chain, Bitcoin miners
are actually allowed--
one little special treat--
they are allowed to include
in that transaction block--
a special node for themselves.
And this node will
basically be a little reward
if they can get-- and
let me use the greenish
color for that
reward-- they could
take the first block,
the first transaction
item, the first
transaction record,
and they can put in that
transaction record-- they
can assign a reward
to themselves.
Now the amount of that
reward will change over time.
But I do want to point out what
this transaction is typically
called is called a coin-based
transaction, or a generation
transaction.
This is how new coins get
included in the Bitcoin system.
So whenever a minor
succeeds in coming up
with a proof as part of
that he'll have been allowed
to come up with his own
transaction to reward himself,
a special little
reward, for extending
the effort necessary to
come up with this proof
and for doing all this
work associated with adding
a new transaction block to
the existing transaction
block chain for Bitcoin.
And I think that's reasonable.
After all these notes are using
a lot of computational power
to come up with these
proofs and if they're
using computational
power that must mean that
somewhere along
the line, somebody
is spending money on
electricity and so on.
Now, I also want to point
out that in addition
to this coin-base
award, the nodes who're
doing the Bitcoin mining,
the ones who succeed.
Also get to collect
the transaction
fees that were specified
in the transaction records.
If you recall, a person issuing
a transaction in Bitcoin
can allocate or set aside a
certain amount of money-- maybe
it can be a Bitcoin or
a fractional Bitcoin--
for the node who
succeeds in coming up
with the actual
proof of working,
and effectively the
node that succeeds
in being able to
add that transaction
to the overall bitcoin
transaction block chain.
And so that node that
does the work succeeds,
gets a reward, another
transaction fee.
Now this could actually
become quite large
because the node will not
only get the transaction
fee before one transaction.
You'll get the transaction
fee for all the transactions
that appeared in
the current block.
It's going to give
the aggregate over all
these different transactions.
Now the second
point I want to make
is that it might be
possible for two nodes
to solve the proof of work
independently of each other.
And somehow, they
both end up trying
to add to that existing
chain in some ways.
You make get some weird
chain forking happening.
If that happens, the peers
in the Bitcoin network
will basically break a tie
by sticking with the longest
chain.
And by longest, I
don't mean the one
that has to be the most
transactions in it.
I really need the one
that has the highest
aggregate difficulty
associated with that underlying
proof of work protocol in each
of the transaction blocks.
And we'll basically look at
the total amount of effort
that was required to generate
that chain with regard
to that proof of work.
And whichever chain has
the most work associated
with it is a chain
that's sacrosanct,
it's a chain that
everybody will accept.
Now you may get some
word discrepancies
because of network
latency issues and so on.
But the idea is that after maybe
a couple of rounds when there
are ties, they'll quickly
resolve themselves
as long as most of the
nodes are being honest
and really stick to the
implementation of the protocol.
Now since Bitcoin miners
are generating bitcoins,
I think there's an interesting
question that comes up here
which is, how is the Bitcoin
money supply, controlled,
and how is it managed?
And I'm going to talk about that
concept in a subsequent video.